physiquement elle est à gauche
chacun a porté un t-shirt pendant
plusieurs nuits ensuite on a fait
analyser le t-shirt par un robot
spécialisés qui a tout de suite
reconstituer les pères deux meilleurs
amis parce que leur odeur était assez
similaire et pour confirmer ces
résultats les chercheurs ont fait un
autre test ils ont réuni dix-sept
personnes qui ne se connaissaient pas du
tout vous avez discuté les unes avec les
autres on leur a demandé qui vous
pourrez y est plutôt copains à la fin
ils ont tous répondu eh bien
l'ordinateur à trouver les mêmes
réponses selon lui leur odeur était
proche plus leurs possibilités d'amitié
et ses forces
[Musique]
les tunnels
regarde regarde c'est trop beau
regardant ce fait comme ça ça fait un
petit hot dogs
et les
bénévoles y seront condamnés des
[Musique]
choses
puisque mon cru bon
[Musique]
morceau de pigeons merci à toute
l'équipe de télématin 1 pour cette
saison fantastique bah je vais le dire
vraiment c j'ai rencontré des gens
formidables et je voulais présenter
d'ailleurs
monsieur jolie monsieur petit monsieur
faure monsieur le vigoureux monsieur
gaillard monsieur rambo monsieur lecoq
monsieur me dit monsieur tête monsieur
euro quand est-ce que ça s'arrête ce
bonheur quand est-ce que ça s'arrête
c'est trop beau il ya quelque chose qui
va arriver c'est sûr mais en fait
carpediem c'est trop bien je profite
voilà nous la voyons donc philippe
ballard il est à droite et monsieur
boyard qui est un jeune personne de 21
ans manifestement mal élevé lui refuse
la main qui lui tendait était venu en
chemise il était là parce que c'est un
des plus jeunes députés de la république
et qu'à ce titre il était à ses soeurs
voilà voilà chacun fait ce qu'il lui
plaît c'est miser
sur le moment j'ai pas compris je suis
monté voté à la tribune en ressent je
lui dis assez bien leur nom est pleine
et puis j'ai eu tant la barre et là en
fait rien je pense que c'était un geste
tout à fait assumé un geste de défiance
hs de la politesse d'intolérance de
manque de respect voire comme certains
députés de la france insoumise ont
l'habitude de pratiquer et je vous dis
c'est françois
le français ah oui ces râleurs abbaoui
mahmoud abbas et ça c'est le râleur
voilà quatre thèmes simmons et des
sourires gênés sourire simon gillett
ça c'est la meilleur jeu bras
au sommet de séoul avait le prix aga
nommé tout de suite ça y est on n'attend
même pas la fin des missions toujours
merci je serai touché parce que j'ai
beaucoup travaillé cette saison puis de
les aimer les sourires